[Music]
the summit's virtual detention reel u.s
president joe biden wanted to meet his
chinese counterpart xi jinping in person
but the chinese leader rejecting all
external invites
the fact the us wants to push ahead
flags the importance of a bilateral
relationship which has hit stalemate i
would argue that the u.s china
relationship is at one of its most
precarious moments that it's been in for
quite some time
china says it's ready to work with the
us to get the relationship back on track
the two super powers have shared
interests there's the fight against
covet the problems with the global
supply chain and global warming
joe biden has had two conversations with
xi jinping since he moved into the oval
office the first didn't happen until
february that delay seen by some as a
deliberate snub for beijing the second
conversation was in september but joe
biden was very critical of ji's decision
not to go to the climate summit in
glasgow
essentially saying that if you want to
be considered a world leader you have to
actually show up to lead
there are tensions between the two most
notably over the chinese crackdown on
pro-democracy protesters in hong kong
the treatment of mainly muslim uighurs
in china and chinese military exercises
near taiwan which the u.s has promised
to defend
one top u.s official says china's
economic growth is changing the global
landscape we're witnessing one of the
largest
shifts in global geostrategic power that
the world has witnessed and it only
happens once in a while china doesn't
want a conflict with the united states
just like the us doesn't want to come
with china and so i think that the idea
of a summit is
essentially an off-ramp it's an
opportunity for the two sides to
lower the temperatures and take stock of
where things are in the relationship
summits rarely happen without something
to show for it so there could be
movement on trade visa restrictions and
perhaps even small moves on nuclear
weapons both sides want to move from
confrontation to cooperation but both
sides need to agree that is the next
step alan fisher al jazeera at the white
house